Minister thank you very much for talking
to Sky News let's first of all focus on
the investigation it is your view it is
the view of the Saudi government that
Iran was responsible for this twin
attack is that right we hold Iran
responsible because the missiles and the
drones were Iranian made we're
investigating more and we have asked the
United Nations to provide us with
experts which they have their in-country
we've asked other countries to do the
same we want to now determine the exact
location from which these missiles were
launched and how close are you to
providing that evidence because there
are skeptics out there quite a lot of
people simply don't believe that this
was the work of the Ron and they take
the Houthi view that this was
self-defense for for your operations in
in Yemen our military explained a few
days ago that impossible for these
missiles to be to come from Yemen
because they don't have the range so
they had to come from somewhere else
plus all indications are all evidences
that they came from the north with
regards to the timing of the investigate
of the investigation I really can't
comment on it because we're not involved
in it and I believe that the technical
experts are going to take their time and
do as thorough an investigation as
possible so that when the conclusions
come out they will be airtight so you're
absolutely convinced that these drones
and missiles came from Iranian soil we
don't know that yet
there's suspicion because they came from
the north but what we do know is that
the missiles and the drones are Iranian
missiles and Iranian drones in Saudi
Arabia prepared for war we hope by any
means to avoid war nobody wants a war
war is destructive we have priorities
that involve reforming our country we
have a responsibility to defend our
country and to ensure that no harm comes
to our country or our people or our
residents and so we will do whatever it
takes to prevent our country from
sustaining damages preparing for war
war is always the last option are you
absolutely convinced that Donald Trump
has your back Donald Trump has been a
very strong president in a very strong
advocate of the us-saudi relationship
Donald Trump has been very firm in
dealing
Iran is committed to enhancing our
military cooperation our security
cooperation so we have no doubt and
Donald is also committed to having fewer
Wars not more Wars so are you not a bit
worried that Matt perhaps he'll want you
to fight this one alone if it comes to
it everybody wants to avoid war
everybody everybody what about the UK
have you asked for a British Britain for
British help militarily the UK had also
has been one of our staunchest allies
when it comes to security and we are
consultants with the United Kingdom on
this area the United Kingdom has agreed
to provide naval assets in order to help
with maritime security the Iranians have
engaged in aggressive behavior for 14
years they have destroyed Lebanon
through Hezbollah they have sent
militias to destroy Syria they have
militias in Iraq they have militias in
Yemen they provide these terrorist
groups with ballistic missiles and
drones and all we want is we want Iran
to start stop acting like a revolution
and try to export this revolution and
start acting like a nation-state stop
supporting terrorists but stop providing
ballistic missiles to terrorist groups
and militias stop your nuclear program
have become a normal country let the
world accept you as the nation in good
standing you said in the news comments
that you think that Iran is trying to
divide the world and that it has haven't
succeeded but maybe it is succeeding
because there are plenty of countries
that that wanted to continue to be in
the Iran nuclear deal there are plenty
of countries that would that want to
take a different approach from that if
Donald Trump and your approach
maybe Iran is actually their plan is
working I don't believe so I think the
world is beginning to realize that
Iran's destructive and aggressive
behavior must come to an end there may
be some issues with regards to tactics
how we bring these things about but
there's no disagreement with regards to
the need to ensure that the nuclear deal
is solid that Iran will not be able to
enrich that the inspection mechanism
becomes stronger and that we have to
deal with the issue of ballistic
missiles and the issue of terrorism and
interference in the affairs of other
countries there's a consensus that these
issues have to be dealt with there may
be some differences in terms of how we
get there we believe that the
does not work there is a suggestion
perhaps it's less likely now that Donald
Trump and president rouhani could meet
in New York would you welcome that or do
you see that as appeasement we believe
that the Iranians are obfuscating and
that they're dragging things out in
order to gain time they could have
talked to the US a year or so ago before
the sanctions were imposed and they
chose not to
now that the sanctions are imposed
they're saying remove the sanctions and
I'll talk to you specifically about the
war in Yemen you're losing this one
aren't you is it's it's time to from a
different approach I'm looking at this
latest UN study it talks about 230,000
people having lost their lives by the
end of this year one child dies every 12
minutes this isn't what you expected in
Yemen two things I would like to say
first on the report we take issue with
the objectivity of the report and the
methodology of the report and the
conclusions of the report and we've made
that clear and we will make it clear to
the United Nations one number two we did
not start this war in Yemen the Houthi
started it and it was a war that was
raging for nine months before we
intervened in order to support the
legitimate government the you may not
have started it but you could finish it
but but the the we cannot allow radical
militia allied with Hezbollah Iran in
possession of ballistic missiles to be
in charge of a strategically important
country the commander of the
Revolutionary Guard in Tehran has said I
think today our readiness to respond to
any aggression is definitive we will
never allow water into our land we will
pursue any aggressor we will continue
until the full destruction of any
aggressor that I think we can read from
that that if there is even a limited
strike on Iran by you by the United
States then that will be in the words of
your counterpart in Tehran all-out war
so I ask again are you prepared for that
and all the consequences we'll do
whatever it takes to protect our nation
period